xem những clip ở phố đầu sánh đầu đầu đó, phố bặt mà,
láo thẳng sẽ vào cạnh xác ra thông biên bắt để thông chốt, người xem không khóa dùng mình.
Sức trẻ chưa thấy đầu chỉ thấy những cố tâm chực dễn khiến nhiều cán bộ chính xí bị thương nào,
còn các quái sẽ tình á nhau ra đường.
Nó sở nhất là các báo tủ này toàn đang đầu tội ăn chưa,
nó đầu chưa tới với bôn đến với tám tuổi.
Chỉ bị máo chiến tích tại hiện các tổ xí dễn háo trên màn,
cây em sẵn sàng đạm lộ lực pháp,
được hiện sẽ đầu không phanh lào liên những con tưu tình.
A quả để lại là gì là những bản án tuổi giám nghiêm các vitor trong người thí hành công vụ.
Lã những gió hôm nước mắt bộ năng mạng của chá mẹ tại đồn công an
hay sự ấn hành tổ công trên dừng bánh với tương tà su đời.